-Guys, can we talk about
"Ghostbusters?"
-"Ghost Spookers."
-"Ghost Spookers: Afterlife,"
or "Ghost Stoppers: Afterlife."
This is --
There's a connection
between this story
and the original "Ghostbusters."
-Everyone that has seen it
says that they cry at the movie,
so it should be an extremely
successful comedy.
[ Laughter ]
-No, there's some great new
creatures, great new fun in it.
The Ecto is doing things
that you never saw it do before.
McKenna Grace
is a spectacular actress,
and she's basically
gonna be our new CEO.
-Yeah.
-And then, we have, of course,
Paul Rudd, a master comedian,
probably.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
You know, as Billy was
the leading comic, you know,
leading man of his generation,
Paul is gonna be taking
that torch up, I think.
-Bill, do you think that you
should be Sexiest Man Alive?
-Yeah, I just happened to notice
out of the corner of my eye
Paul'S --
-Yeah. I was --
-Paul's mom comes around
with this magazine.
-I came in 103rd.
-Paul's mom comes around?
-Paul's mom has been walking
up and down the halls
with this magazine.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-She bought all the copies?
She's very proud.
She's a very proud mom, yeah.
-She's great.
And Carrie's great.
Carrie Coon, she's great.
Just a fantastic cast.
-What's it like
to put the suit back on?
Did you ever think
you'd do it again?
-You know,
I never thought we would,
up until I got there
and I realized
it's actually happening.
But I will say,
when I got in the suit
and Bill and Dan
and seeing Sigourney,
it was almost spiritual, man.
I was almost in tears.
It was great.
-What was it like
putting the suit back on, Bill?
Did it go, well?
-It hurt.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I'm so sorry.
-It was a lot of pain.
And, you know, the nice thing
about working
with a classically trained guy
is that he helps you
back to your feet.
-Wow, exactly right.
-For some reason, they just --
these directors just
like to say, "Okay, now you guys
are all down on the ground,"
you know,
with this thing on your back.
And then you got to roll over
like a dead bug
and try to get up while wearing
a, you know, a vacuum cleaner."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But it was -- you had shock
waves of memory from it.
You went, "Oh, God.
This is horrible."
'Cause it was really
very, very long days.
And it was a very heavy thing.
It's not as heavy as the
original was, but we're weaker,
so it's about the same.
[ Laughter ]
-You've actually become weaker,
of course.
I'm so happy
that you're here on the show,
and I love you guys so much.
Thank you so much.
-Thanks, Jimmy,
for having us on.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's a peak
at "Ghostbusters: Afterlife."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Switch rattles ]
-[ Roars ]
-[ Screams ]
[ Glass shatters ]
-Yes!
-Uh...
We should probably
get out of here.
-You're an adult.
-Yeah.
And liable.
-You know what this means,
right?
Your grandfather
was a Ghostbuster.
-Yeah, that's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to the one and only
Bill Murray, Dan Aykroyd,
Ernie Hudson!
"Ghostbusters: Afterlife"
hits theaters this Friday.